[Music]
you guys ready to go to maine
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right guys all right let's check
this place out
oh my goodness a ping pong paddle
and a foosball table
it's time for bed guys bedtime bedtime
bedtime go go go
upstairs hey you guys come on out of
there
we've got the kids to bed and it's been
a very long day
but we're gonna snuggle on the couch and
go to bed at a reasonable time and i'll
see you guys in the morning
good morning we're on parker pond this
little lake has
uh salmon trout bass
a whole bunch of other things you can
ice fish for but i'm not sure if the ice
is thick enough we're definitely gonna
have to check the ice today
but i'm hungry i'm gonna make some
breakfast
our first day in maine and we're having
a very southern breakfast
biscuits and gravy
all right it's time to find out how
thick the ice is
ah maybe two inches it's two inches here
it might be okay
out there but i ain't gonna go out and
find out
[Music]
should we get some dinner guys yeah yeah
a little sweet steak sauce here locally
made
[Music]
[Applause]
so my sister and her family are joining
us your waffles
this little guy is all partied out so
i'm gonna go take him to bed
i'll see you guys in the morning
you guys ready to go on a little bit of
an adventure yeah all right let's go
okay
all right guys got the whole crew here
and we're gonna go on a ferry to a
little island
and uh we're gonna do a little
wintertime beach combing so
we're gonna give that a go
my wife absolutely loves fairies in all
shapes and forms
i do i love fairies being married so
nice
you go from trying to figure out what
women want to only having to figure out
what one woman wants it makes life so
much simpler
so guys we're on peaks island maine
and uh we're gonna go searching for sea
glass
which is broken glass that gets washed
up in the sea and
polished
lucy is taking this very seriously
where'd you find lucy
mask makeout
oh there's the lighthouse all right
we're here at an old military fort
that has a lighthouse and my wife the
only thing she loves more than fairies
lighthouses
oh i think we lost jacob
well i better eat up well because
tomorrow is supposed to be a low
of eight degrees fahrenheit and me and
nathan are going camping
without a tent so i need to build an
extra layer of fat to survive tomorrow
night
on top of the current layer well me and
nathan are heading to flume gorge in the
franconia notch state park area
in the white mountains of new hampshire
which is not that far away it's only
about an hour drive
all right buddy we're here
[Music]
um
[Music]
oh that's cool
[Music]
so
what do you think jason is this cool
oh we need to find a little cave like
that but one without water going through
it
[Music]
[Applause]
it's been fun but it's time to leave the
trail behind
[Music]
oh i see a big rock we could build a
shelter up against this rock
we'd have water nearby yeah look at that
that's pretty cozy yeah it wouldn't take
much to build a nice spot
hi daddy hi bud do we camp here
it's a little lumpy i'm not gonna lie
but
it's better than most
all right
[Applause]
daddy
hey crawling
that'll keep the chimney from melting
the tarp right there we're gonna need to
get a lot of firewood
luckily there's a lot of dead wood
around
that'll do
so
well it's getting dark quickly and the
sun's about to set and i have spent the
last three hours cutting firewood and i
think i have plenty but nathan's been
sleeping and taking a little bit of a
nap which
makes me happy here i'm gonna get the
the tent all warm and get some food made
and i'm gonna wake him up
all right i've got a cotton ball and i
put some petroleum jelly on it
and uh we're gonna light this sucker on
fire
and uh it light
very well
hey buddy you have a good nap
all right here we go
let's grab it with the handle it's it's
hot just
whatever you do you cannot spill it in
your bed
that tastes good bud good
so
yeah chicken teriyaki
yeah that tastes good
yeah be real careful that's good hot
chocolate
yep it's right now so you're still
hungry
i have a snack bag
for just such an issue now we have some
halloween candy
we have giant marshmallows strawberry
and vanilla
oh that feels nice
well it's only about seven o'clock and
uh nathan had a pretty long nap
so i promised him we'd watch some tv
shows on my phone and
we're just gonna snuggle up all warm in
our sleeping bags and
hang out together for a little bit i'm
gonna keep this fire going and
we'll see it's supposed to get really
cold tonight
it was a high in the 20s today and the
low is
probably going to be in the single
digits
got a little bit of snow last night
good to see smoke coming out of that
thing oh
i really should have brought a pee
bottle i hate getting out to go to the
bathroom
oh excuse me all right it's breakfast
time
we got biscuits and gravy freeze-dried
hey nathan you sleep well yeah good
all right we've got some breakfast
marshmallows
what do you think david is that a
perfect marshmallow yep
there you go breakfast marshmallows
you ready to get out of your sleeping
bag and get dressed
well i'm not in love with the idea of
getting out of my sleeping bag
i am excited for the hike back though
we're not just gonna backtrack the way
we came we're gonna go a different route
and uh we're gonna hike past a gorge and
some waterfalls and see some pretty cool
scenery so
i'm looking forward to that but first i
need to get up and get packed
oh oh no i stacked my boots up on my
sleeping bag last night
look what happened
oh i gotta go out there without shoes
and go get them and dry them off
gonna use my clown shoes
oh that looks cold
uh it's taken down the tarp and the tarp
fell onto the stove for just a second
and burned a hole right in it
oh this was a fun campsite this turned
out a lot better than i expected
you ready nate yeah let's do it i'll
follow you
i swear that backpack's bigger than you
are nathan you ready to go downhill nate
we're gonna die
i killed david are you okay
you're still gonna go ahead and run
downhill yeah even though you've crashed
twice aren't you
[Laughter]
we don't learn our lessons we don't
learn our lesson
at least i didn't do that one
oh careful you don't tear your pants
whoa
look at that yeah we gotta hike all the
way around
yeah look at this
you know there's so many awesome hikes
that get kind of ruined
because they're too popular but you come
in the winter time like this
oh you get it all to yourself it's just
so nice
we're close to the end
there's the car we're here man i was
really worried about that being too cold
that worked out really well though we
melted our tarp
we might have to go to rei
it says survival camping tactical gear
boots and backpacks yeah we'll get some
army stuff
doggy assist me should we get this for
tommy and jacob
[Music]
well good morning it's another beautiful
day and we've got
some guests coming to visit zach fowler
with the youtube channel fowler's makery
and mischief
apparently lives nearby and uh he's
gonna pop over
and we're gonna do some ice fishing
right here at the property
all righty you guys they like your
pancakes yeah
becca this day is starting off so nice
isn't it lovely
and the boys have been so well behaved
and playing well together and
so quiet wait a minute who did this to
you
nathan all right i'm sorry to inform you
but nathan will no longer be featured in
any of our videos
nathan where are you luckily it was only
a dry erase marker although nathan was
supposed to be using his dry erase
marker for school
not to color on his brother mom did a
good job that dry erase marker came out
hey come on in hello
you got to wrap around and everything
look at that nice
oh that's firmed up a lot
what oh yeah what was that three four
inches that's uh
probably five that's wicked solid so
zach's got
all the fancy schmancy electronics here
so he's got
fish finders that allow him to put a
sensor down the hole and look around and
see if there's any fish
around the hole so this is this is my
kind of fishing here
it's got a little structure right there
like weeds or something
possibly yeah
there you go see the lead in the minnow
right there the orange things the lead
the little
dot above it's the minnow so we can see
fish this big on the sonar
sit on your bottom
get set go
i'm waiting i'm winning
[Music]
well i was out getting the hot dog zach
pulled up three perch
looked at that one
there hey i just got there in school yes
oh there he is there he is buddy
just yeah hey hold that string tom there
you go
your first main fish before he freezes
there you go you just got to hit buddy
here just a little bit pop pop pop
see there you go yeah you got one i just
really
as fast as i can okay slow down slow it
slow down oh
there you go sticking his gills out
there you go
all right so here's your hot dog some
chinese brats and tommy's got some
cheddar hot dogs
we're cooking up some good stuff i
wonder if it is just ground red short
rib
gotta try these sweet chinese brats here
yeah all right we got some mango chutney
here
that looks good
it could be the hypothermia in my lips
but that's tastes
really really good oh there we go
little beasty there we go slightly
larger than the minnows
oh all about freshening up the worm
well guys we had a great time we tore up
the perch and ate a lot of good
hot dogs but uh sunset i think it's time
to pack it up
go find out what the kids are up to
[Applause]
do you want orange or black this is the
slingshot ammo see these are steel balls
a trapping card hooks sewing needle
uh that's a tick puller right there and
those are the trap triggers
you know mr fowler is a slingshot expert
you know that
the fowler series the sparrow
thank you very much dad i appreciate
that now in case you guys haven't done
this already make sure to check out zach
fowler's channel
fowler's makery and mischief and i'll
put a link in the video description down
below
so check that out for a lot of really
cool survival videos all right
all right guys you have a safe trip
we're going on another camping adventure
tomorrow so
i think i better go to bed see you guys
in the morning well good morning we're
just hanging out here eating some
breakfast and taking it easy the boys
have a little bit of school this morning
so i'm gonna use that time to pack and
get ready for a camping trip and as soon
as
nathan is done with school we're gonna
go on another adventure
[Music]
[Music]
can we follow this creek all right let's
see what happens
look at this nathan
yeah let's keep going and see if we find
the bottom of the canyon
over here
[Music]
holy mackerel
that's cool should we go see if we can
find our way down there
there's like a whole cave behind that
waterfall of ice
how's that one
this place is cool look at this we're
just
right in the middle of this little
canyon here
look how clear this ice is it's like
crystal
you just see right through it
it's nathan the narwhal now i'm eating a
bagel
now i'm eating a bagel bagel
with these in
oh you want to come back here watch out
you get wet buddy
yeah look at this oh
this is like you're on the back side of
an ice waterfall
is that cool
see if i can do this without without
biting it
hold on nate don't slip
all right nathan i think this looks like
an awesome spot
let's find some dead trees
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
ugh
yeah karate dab
i'm always super paranoid that i'm going
to run out of firewood in the middle of
the night and so i always
end up gathering way more than i need
but i think i've got a good pile for
right now
i think we need to get the shelter up
um
daddy
do you want spaghetti or cup of noodle
all right cup of little it is
now you can boil water by putting a
kettle on top of the stove but it's not
particularly fast
and nathan's really hungry so i busted
out my little back up
butane stove which i always carry with
me and this thing will boil water
pretty quick
all right nathan are ramen noodles your
favorite camping food
oh some warm food feels good
congratulations you still hungry buddy
here we'll eat one of these little
survival bars
well we're getting ready to go to bed
and i have learned my lesson from
previous winter camping trips i brought
a wide
neck bottle yeah we're not getting out
of our bag tonight
good night buddy
there's a lot of salt and ramen broth
you know how cold it's got to get to
freeze that solid
jeez i thought water bottle
well here on the outdoor boys channel we
post new videos
every saturday morning and it's 7 a.m on
a saturday morning
so i've got to walk out of this canyon
to get enough cell service to be able to
post my video
there we go there's your new video oh
i'm gonna go back by that fire it's cold
out here
my hands are frozen
oh it was cold last night my bag was
barely keeping it together
hey nathan were you warm yeah
nathan's bag is so much better than mine
i gotta get one of those
yeah nathan's got the feather friends
plover it's a negative 25 bag
it is so sweet and the best part is
feathered friends
will customize the length for you and so
i had them shorten it so it's a
perfect nathan sized bag
you ready for some oatmeal bud
[Music]
as much as i hate to say it i think i
need to get dressed and get
up and doing stuff it is
cold
there's a lot of these really cool rock
formations to explore around here and as
soon as we get done breaking camp
i want to go hike to a frozen waterfall
and i think we might be able to find a
cave as well so
that's going to be kind of cool but
first i need to get cleaned up in case
you're wondering how i secured the tarp
to this rock face
i just had these little wooden wedges
and i jammed into the cracks right there
and over on this side i tied it off to
an icicle now we're going to get our
tarp off without
letting it touch the stove and get
melted like i did last time
[Music]
well this has been one of the coolest
places i've ever camped
but uh i think it's time to go explore
some more stuff
you wanna go hike and see a cave in
waterfall yeah all right let's drop our
packs here so we don't have to carry
them up we'll come back for them okay
we'll just stash them behind the tree
over here
[Applause]
well look at that that cave full of
icicles
oh look at this this is cool
oh look careful don't fall down here bud
careful but don't slip down there
there's a big creek down there
there was a small cave at the bottom of
that ravine
but it looked like it had three feet of
water in the bottom i thought maybe the
water be frozen this time of year we
could get in it but
i would hate to fall down that thing and
be stuck in that
bought the water it's all of his money
yeah it's so pretty in the wintertime he
okay
oh trail is getting a bit faint
oh this is pretty awesome nate you glad
we came here well there's supposed to be
a big waterfall around here too
but i'm not sure if we can are find
crazy man you're taking your coat off
that boy's crazy
there we go right where we left it i'm
so glad you came with me on this camp
out nathan
yeah did you have fun yeah let's go home
and see mama and cousins
well good morning and welcome to our
last full day here in maine
[Music]
um
things are coming oh it was fun having
my sister and her family come visit
but uh they're heading back so zack
fowler's daughter forgot her boots
and so we're gonna go on a little road
trip and go uh go see him at his place
i think we're in the right place
[Applause]
hello
we got the lose mach 2 here we got the
blow guns here
this is what we call survival deco it is
my kind of interior design here
carving them in there the days of the
week and then it's like at the top that
was my ten items and fish head for fish
head soup
this is from the duck hunter 3000 it had
a propeller on it when i was in
patagonia
look at that man that is a slingshot
collection
all right that was like third try
you got it
i was like zach makes a good looking
pizza though rectangle slices
out of a round pizza you're a madman
zach
and half marinara sauce you get this
kind of it's good pizza
the rosemary on the pan all right kids
it's way past your bedtime
you guys come down to virginia we'll
we'll show you around definitely
all right oh well it's the morning of
our last day here in maine and we're
just cleaning up the rental house and
eating some breakfast and we're gonna
hit the road here real soon we've had
a really good time
well guys did you have fun yeah yeah
that was a good time
time to drive 11 hours back to virginia
well guys i hope you enjoyed this video
as much as we enjoyed this trip
don't forget to click subscribe to the
outdoor boys youtube channel and check
out our travel
and adventure playlist and remember we
put out new videos
every saturday morning so i'll see you
then bye
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos
every saturday morning and hit that bell
button you'll get notifications
thanks for watching